well tomorrow is national sunday day and
to celebrate why not have the ice cream
sundae of your dreams
rocky these is live at sloanes in the
venetian to show us where ice cream
fantasies become reality
hey if they've got a unicorn then
they've got an ice cream fantasy
actually denise that's perfect because
i'm carrying this cutie pie for you i
figured
if i was going to pick anything it would
be the unicorn because you are a unicorn
okay there we go all right let's talk
about ice cream now okay you said all of
our ice cream fantasies and i
have a feeling that um this could
suffice yeah
only a little closer this is called the
kitchen sink america tell us all about
it
so you're gonna have 18 scoops four of
our 18 scoops of ice cream oh my god
eight four brownies four cuties and all
my top and it's a dry top into a topping
so you're gonna have marshmallow
m m chocolate peanuts everything is
gonna be in there
oh my gosh okay so when people come for
example tomorrow for national sunday day
how do they order this how do they eat
it because like this is not something
you can just
walk through the venetian with don't
take home yeah so we're gonna have it
ready for you guys and tell me the
flavors we're going to make it for you
obviously you get your spoon right the
only deal here is that you cannot take
this thing home
of course okay you can have it as long
as you want you can experience
how long you want it so just make sure
you're ready to eat ice cream yeah
you're ready for all the chocolate
and just dig in oh my gosh this is
amazing i wish that i could bring this
back to the station because i know some
of your
mouths are salivating but let's talk
about everything else you guys have here
obviously this is the kitchen sink we
showed you
the sandcastle is going to be the sand
castle sunday what other sundays can
they get tomorrow
so we have a s'more sundaes we have a
luxury sample
that will be nice small scoop so you can
if you don't know what ice cream go with
yeah you can go with that sampler
so that's a good idea here um our cookie
wish it would be two of our
big cookies in it how did i make a mess
i'm not even eating
that's a good sunday when you know
you're making a mess all right and then
it will be two of the big cookies with
ice cream mayonnaise we
found all right classic sunday if you
want to go a little bit basic
and okay good and i don't you know i
don't even know if you can say basic in
here okay because this is just
not your basic ice cream shop and i want
to tell you guys about this
apple pie ice cream okay on the menu you
guys when i
bit into this there was a whole apple
in it okay so they've actually make the
apple pies
and then put them in the ice cream
yourselves so what we do we have to bake
the pie so we caramelize the apples we
put in
wow we baked that for you guys and then
we blended in on our vanilla cinnamon
incredible i love it here can i stay
and oh so i brought denise the unicorn i
brought david the count because he's a
boss
yeah what do i get for ted one more
little thing okay
get it get it happy national sunday day
tomorrow come celebrate oh by the way
veterans eat
ice cream free tomorrow yes so come on
down